عناي الاعم الذين
قعك الذين كفروا بايات هم و
[Silence]
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
نا و
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا الله
اشهد
ان
اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول رسول
الله اشهد ان
محمد
رسول الله
حي على
[Silence]
الفلا حي على الصلاه
حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلا
حي على
[Silence]
الفلاح الله اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن
يدلله واشهد ان اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله صفي بخلق وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وعد
الامانه ونصح الامه وكشف الله تعالى به
غمه وجاهد في الله حق جهاد حتى اته
اليقين اما بعد فقال الله سبحانه وتعالى
في القران المجيد والفرقان الحميد بعد
قولوا اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله تقاته ولا
تموتن الا وانم مسلمون ثم اما بعد ان اصدق
الكتاب كتاب الله تعالى وخير هدي هدي محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم وشر الامور محدثها وكل
محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في
النار رب اشرحلي صدري ويسرلي امري واحلل
عقده من لساني يفقه قولي اللهم لا سحل الا
ما جعلته سح وانت تجعل الحنا اذا شئت سح
ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
الله ربنا وفقت ورجاؤنا ومولان فنعم المى
ونعم النصير
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
[Silence]
اللهانه الله سبحانه
وتى كتاب انزلناه اليك مبارك
ليدبروا وليتذكر
قصلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏isic
aent mind
الله
سبالى ا تقرون
[Silence]
اللهون كان الله الله معذبهم وهم ي
سه ابراهيم ان شاء
الله واذن ربكم ل ان شكرتم
لازيد are i inre
[Silence]
‏gr
gra bliss
[Silence]
‏one
being love for
him
for and the only that people about
gratitude rather
واما بنعمه
ربك بنعمه ربك
مفسرون رحمه الله
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى حث رسول الله صلى عليه
وسلم علسلام
ال
[Silence]
بال
الله
[Silence]
سالر there
‏people
[Silence]
واما بنعمه ربك فحدث
‏jeneve
job more
[Silence]
حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان الله يحب ان يرى اثر نعمه على
عبده
الله حثر
[Silence]
‏don't
الله
سبهالى رحمه الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله المه
الله
سانتال would like
come bled
[Silence]
الله سبحان
وتالى ادا شكق من عبا
شكران عليهه
عليهه
[Silence]
الله دا
عليه
الله الدا
شك الله
موى
عل
سبهالى
الله
own ل
ملائك ودخلت
جنه ثم
تبت
all
caning thank you for
all that upon
[Silence]
سبحانه الحمدله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
[Silence]
‏i know and may
was sayk you
because because he a he might
back the
wech my
الحمد لله
ربال الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
وقالى كم ادعوني استجب لكم
وقال كم
ادعوني
ask ‏right means me give
not
present as قران وقال
كم ادعوني استجب لكم
حديث
حسن ما على الارض مسلم يدعو الا بدعوته
الا اتاه الله اياها وصرف عنه من السوء
مثلها ولم يدعوا باثم او قطيه رحم فقال
رجل من قومي اذا نكثر قال اكثر الله او
كما قال عليه الصلاه والسلام
[Silence]
رسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم رسول الله
الله سبحانه وتالى رول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله
[Silence]
الله beau
الحدم
[Silence]
‏as حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم رسول الله
صلحه do not
make سحه
are رول الله صلى الله عليه
وسم ياول
الله
one
ياول رسول عليه
وسم i
have
for
we for our
personals but as my is concerned i hav
done anything
on now
‏so fl comm
as
days
me other
الله سبحانه
وتالى
حثر رول صلى
اقول ما تسمعون استغفر الله ولي ولكم
وسائل المسلمين فاستغفر الغفور
[Silence]
الرحيم الحمد لله الواحد الاحد الفرض
الصمد الذي لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له ك
احد عن
جابر عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال من
يشكر القليل لم يشكر الكثير ولم يشكر
الناس لم يشكر الله عز وجل او كما قال
عليه الصلاه والسلام حدي
حث
حثث جابر رضي الله عنه
اللهصلى
علس من لم يش
القليل grae for the small things never
gra
things my brs my
sisters beled you att because the fa we
have can
‏eyes the
tong the brain the
ears given us
are tool given us
take الله سانتال
[Silence]
اللهه
حث those
are
be know
‏listening eyes resp
sing from الله سبحانه
وتالى حث
حث ولم
يشر الله سبحانه
وتالى a life
[Silence]
اللهانه وتالى
الله
[Silence]
شاء الله
تعالى اللهم لا تدع الا غفرت ولا
الا ولات مض الا شافيت ولا د ق
اولا اصلحت ولا اوحت ولا اولا اصلحت ولا
عرت ولا
حجرت لنا اللهم ان كان رزقنا في السماء
فانزله كان بعيدا فقربه وان كان بعيدا
فقربه فكثره كان كثرا فبارك لنا فيه
واعلموا ان الله كد لكم امرا بدا في نفسه
ولمس ولى بكم مع جن عنس قال قائمنا عليما
ان الله وملائكته يصلون على النبي الين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلم اللهم سلم وبارك
علىك محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين عباد
الله ان الله يامركم بالعدل والاحسان وتاء
ذي القرب وانحن فاشا منكر بغي يعيذ لعلكم
تذكرون اذكروا الله العظيم اذكركم اشكركم
وذكر الله اكبر وقوم الى يرحمكم
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا الله
استت الله
سبحانه الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحم
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الض
ين
امين والتين
والزيتون وطور
سينين وهذا البلد
الامين لقد خلقنا
الانسان في احسن
تقويم ثم
رددناه اسفل
سافلين الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
فلهم اجر غير
ممنون فما يكذبك بعد
بالدين اليس الله باحكم الحاكمين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين والعصر
ان
الانسان لفي
خصر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا
بالحق وتواصوا بالحق
الصبر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله
sch ان شاء
الله ان شاء اللهن
تالى and
reges for ‏the prr on
for sch trans pleas to
me ان شاء
الله جزاك الله خير
[Silence]
‏ja
الس ‏s
[Silence]
‏f
‏s
[Silence]
الله بارك
‏tr
‏z
[Silence]
‏fire
ج
[Silence]
‏r
‏g
[Silence]
‏e
‏every
[Silence]
خ
‏eh
[Silence]
الله
م
[Silence]
‏pres
‏ex
[Silence]
ا
‏h
[Silence]
‏e
‏pr
[Silence]
‏ja